[Music]
so I found out that hosting a show means
every once in a while the writers will
send you out to do something that you
are uncomfortable with obviously that
makes me uh quite
uncomfortable so with that in mind
here's a video of me ice skating for the
very first time in my life with two
Olympic hopefuls let's check that
out why don't you to say what you just
said to me if I go
down we can't save you it's great I'll
try my best though thanks Max this is uh
truly and legitimately terrifying this
is no bit I I've never ice skated in my
life and I'm here with two of the
world's best ice skaters in the world
Max Aaron and Gracie Gold who have
graciously agreed to uh Shepherd me can
we use Shepherd I like that word
shephered me on I can't stress enough
that this isn't for a bit I don't want
to do this my producer Orin says it's a
good idea and it'll be funny so I'll
follow you okay are you ready to March
no no no I don't want to do that that no
hands TR test take the hands okay now
you're going to March like are you okay
with swearing yeah I'm 18 now you're oh
good dicks oh God in heaven we shouldn't
be here okay you okay can we March a
little better what does March mean let's
see if he can do it on his own come on
you're a marching band stand up now just
March is let's just March March why do
you keep saying marching we're on Ice
yeah that's how you stand before you
Glide lose the tune young lady or I will
take away too or your Game Boy or
whatever it is you young people are up
to this isn't so bad you can distract me
as you're doing this that's the key you
got to distract me and one more
time oh Jesus Oh my Jesus I didn't like
you're you're pure evil I will burn down
your childhood homes if I fall I swear
to God I will find you I'm scared I'm
scared look you're gling oh my God look
at that do you want a sticker for your
sticker card your sarcasm is palpable
thanks do you know palpable I swear I'm
going to attack you oh every time I get
angry at you I'm better at skating
you're a good teacher I'm emitting a
scent right now that alerts my family to
rescue me it's a panic I'm going to
shoot you both with a crossbow I swear
do you have one I wish I did an antique
crossbow they have that event where uh
you ski and then you shoot a gun maybe
we could do skating and then I I shoot
you guys with cross I don't know why I'm
teasing you I'm so dependent on you
right now oh yeah oh Glide
wow oh no this isn't what God wanted for
my
life no no no no no oh go Bruins 1 1
two oh you push harder than that come on
you're a man you both give me a man pose
oh oh I like that one that was good can
we get a little hip in there little it's
a little Blaze of Glory right oh dick oh
sticks that's a lot of that's a lot
of like beefing right on on on the show
dick balls and ass everybody you
you are sass to the Max and I'd really
like to sincerely apologize for
everything I said to you in the past 10
minutes I didn't mean it I'd like to
have a crossbow too I forgot about that
one yeah you said you would kill us I
didn't mean
it uh I meant it I meant every word ice
skating is for small people tall people
we're better at picking elusive fruits
if you know what a kiwi tastes like
thank a tall person we'll be right
[Music]
back